[Musique]
et avec nous pour en débattre mathieu
hutin rédacteur en chef de la radio h 20
dans les alpes
vous êtes arrivé vous arrivez une drôle
de mésaventure récemment m suppute un
pardon on va en parler dans quelques
instants à vos côtés alexandre langlois
secrétaire général du syndicat policier
vigie bonsoir à vous aussi alexandre
langlois merci d'être avec nous
continuons à nous battre pour qu'ils
restent libres continuons à nous battre
contre la désinformation qui menacent
nos démocraties cette petite phrase est
signée emmanuel macron et elle a piqué
pas mal de journalistes avant de vous
faire réagir je voudrais vous faire
écouter l'un d'entre eux en tant que
journaliste je trouve ces propos
indécents quand on a fait passer les
lois les plus liberticides de ces
dernières décennies et qu'on s'applique
chaque jour à essayer de bâillonner la
presse indépendante
la moindre des choses c'est de nous
épargner cette tirade dans cette
journaliste pas vraiment contente vous
mathieu comment vous analysé
cette sortie du président l'a pressé et
libre comme on l'imaginé où il y a des
doutes aujourd'hui
bonsoir c'est fanny de muri bonsoir
alexandre langlois la radio s'appelle
h2o juste au passage comment j'analyse
7,8 du chef de l'état si je voulais être
acide mais je vais l'être
je dirais que l'on ferait pavé de bonnes
intentions on ne peut pas faire preuve
de deux dossiers bonnes intentions dans
la mesure où il ya cet article 24 il ya
cette loi de sécurité global extrêmement
contestée et cristallise et qui
cristallise les relations entre les
forces d'ordre les journalistes alors
qu'elle ne l'était pas et vous avez
parlé de ce rapport il ya quelques
minutes dans un sujet ce rapport il dit
que c'est remonte cinq ans en arrière
les relations entre les journalistes et
les forces de l'ordre
elle était bonne comment on en est
arrivé là j'espère qu'on va pouvoir en
parler avec alexandre l'emploi alors
justement alexandre royer pardon pour
évidemment la coquille sur sur votre
radio h2o pour le quel regard porte le
policier sur cette question est-ce que
clairement
les journalistes peuvent faire leur
boulot en france sans pression vous qui
avez l'habitude du terrain alexandre
langlois bonsoir bonsoir votre invité
non il ya une répression y la police est
même utilisé pour justement mettre la
pression aux journalistes donc
évidemment ce qu'on voit sur le terrain
avec la sécurité loi globale la loi est
faite pour mettre pression sur les
journalistes parce que des lois
protègent déjà les policiers mieux que
ce que prévoit cette cette loi on a une
collection versailles qui a été filmé
par des captations d'image pour lui
nuire la personne qui a fait ça + 17
mois de prison ferme sans la loi la
deuxième chose on a aussi le nouveau
schéma du maintien de l'ordre en
septembre dernier qui dit que babette
ans les journalistes devront souvent est
accrédité par le ministère l'intérieur
où la préfecture pour pouvoir suivre des
manifestations et si on leur demande de
se disperser donc moment où
l'information peut être intéressant
qu'ils devront se soumettre aux
injonctions et puis pour finir on a pu
voir toute ces derniers temps la teinte
aussi à aux sources des journalistes
on a eu des perquisitions des tentatives
de perquisitions chez médiapart dans la
sphère benalla nous avons dix
journalistes convoqué la dg ici le
journaliste du monde dans l'affairé
mediapart des journalistes plus
indépendant sur les armes de la france
au yémen
nous avons eu encore récemment dans la
sphère semelle pâti des journalistes de
libération qui sont cette fois ci passer
à l'igpn
donc nous voyons bien que la police ait
complètement détournée de ses missions
pour protéger l'état et ça pose un
sérieux problème sur l'indépendance des
journalistes en france
alors m vous par exemple vous
avez été poursuivis récemment pour avoir
couvert une manifestation sur le tarmac
d'un aéroport den si je le disais en
début et au tribunal vous vous êtes
étonné bien des désarmement du ministère
public qui vous a comparé à des
militants racontez nous oui
effectivement on a été assimilée dans la
procédure à des militants parce qu'au
tout début de de cette manifestation ont
tout s'est extrêmement bien passé on a
seize minutes d'une manifestation
pacifiste avec 15 militants d'extinction
robes à lyon une intervention des forces
de l'ordre que nous on connaît parce
qu'on fait de la police justice sur le
terrain nous on est dans une petite
ville de province dont tout le monde se
connaît les forces de l'ordre savent qui
on est et puis elles arrivent elles sont
2 au début en deux gendarmes qui arrive
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport les
militants et la presse allez allez
quitter le le lieu de la manifestation
et puis ça fige ça fige les deux
journalistes disent personne ne bouge et
puis finalement
on voit une voiture de voitures trois
voitures et à la fin au bout d'une
demi-heure tout de même les les
gendarmes sont plus nombreux que les
manifestants
on évacue tout le monde dans le calme ça
se passe super bien en ce que les
militants de d'ixair sont pacifistes
puis nous on n'avait pas non plus de
raison de se rebeller même si on
s'étonne mais on nous le dit en catimini
comme on nous le dit à la faim en
sortant du tarmac bas les journalistes
vous allez venir aussi vous expliquer la
gendarmerie et puis à la gendarmerie
bon on fait un peu pression sur nous
pour qu'on explique comment on savait
qu'il y avait une manifestation ce qui
est pas tolérable mais ça peut être
compris comme de de la maladresse en
tout cas moi aujourd'hui formellement je
ne sais pas s'il y avait un ordre de
nous faire parler sur ça aussi c'est une
simple maladresse de gendarmes puis moi
je veux accuser personne parce qu'on a
des bonnes relations avec les gendarmes
ici et puis les gendarmes nous disent
bon bah finalement vous serez sortie de
la procédure
sauf qu'on se retrouve convoquée au
tribunal de police à devoir s'expliquer
et à devoir dire non non nous étions un
journaliste est le motif pour lequel
nous étions là et est valable si on
prend le rapport la liste de
recommandations parce que c'est quand
même intéressant on a mis des magistrats
on a mis des policiers on a mis des gens
de la presse autour d'une table ça s'est
passé au ministère de l'intérieur sous
la présidence de jean marie delarue qui
conseiller d'état et on sort 32
propositions la liste des
recommandations ont été faites hier et
dans l'est dans les recommandations
c'est clair et c'est net on doit pouvoir
couvrir des manifestations
même si elles sont illégales ou non
déclarés c'est curieux quand même
alexandra quand vous écoutez ce
témoignage ça vous évoque quoi vous vous
déplorez j'imagine ces relations qui
sont peut-être plus tendue qu'avant la
faute à quoi à qui s'est notamment le
contexte de la loi c'est que global qui
étend les choses vous disiez tout à
l'heure ça m'a interpellé on se sert de
la police contre les manifestants qui
cesseront non c'est le gouvernement le
ronge et réclamant le gouvernement les
politiques ce car les ordres viennent du
ministère de l'intérieur la préfecture
de police qui sont les préfets sont des
personnes nommées par les politiques les
grands directeurs de la police qui ont
peur pour leur poste ou qui cherchent
des avancements dans les départements
donc c'est contre les manifestants oui
on utilisa police mais contre la presse
également parce qu'en fait on a ce
gouvernement plutôt que d'avoir une
police républicaine est propre on ses
actions ou alors dans les gens qui
veulent manifester en face d'eux en fait
ils préfèrent cacher mais que la
poussière
sous le tapis il ya aussi eu un rapport
aussi de l'onu sur la loi sécurité
globale qui dénonce ce qui se passe
également en france sur la liberté de la
presse
on n'est pas non plus très bien classé
dans la liberté de la presse mondiale 30
34e
donc il ya plein de choses qui sont
inquiétantes et ça pose des problèmes
parce que les services de police on
travaille en général en bonne
intelligence avec la presse parce que ça
permet des fois de prévenir certaines
actions de passer encadrer correctement
que les gens fassent leur travail
bon en bonne intelligence moi je sais
que pour avoir travaillé sur le terrain
régulièrement que la presse en tant que
rembourser - territoriales à chaque fois
pour éviter le comptage selon la police
selon la presse sont les manifestants on
réunissait tout le monde ont compté
ensemble et ça se déroulait dans une
ambiance bonne enfant
chacun est utile à tout le monde et à
partir de là on a une volonté du pouvoir
en fait de cacher tout ce qui va contre
lui et donc là on est sur quelque chose
d'une dérive qui pose de nombreux
problèmes et à poney censure continue
également au delà de la police on a eu
des lois anti fait que 12 qui décide qui
fait l'affectueuse il ya des censures
qu'arrive à tel point que c'est
tellement ridicule que même le
gouvernement puisse et effet censuré
pendant parler les européennes par
twitter donc on voit bien que les lois
sont tellement mal ficelé qu'on sait
plus qui a le droit de dire quoi qui a
le droit de couvrir quoi donc ça pose un
sérieux problème sur la liberté
d'information et la liberté
d'information est nécessaire et en fait
toutes ces lois crise que des relations
qui étaient bien et en fait on crée des
problèmes où il n'y en avait pas avant
mathieu est un vous avez ce même
diagnostic le gouvernement aimerait bien
donner peut-être une bonne image et est
caché un petit peu ce qui va pas dans
son sens c'est aussi votre avis sur le
terrain vous vous partagez
moi je n'ai pas constaté ça parce que
j'ai pas de preuve factuelle pour vous
l'affirmer comme le dit alexandre
langlois qui est policier et et il ne
pourra faire une personne pour mieux le
dire que lui par contre qui d'autre
aurait intérêt effectivement à ce que ça
se passe de cette façon là moi je vous
le redis que les personnes de terrain
les gendarmes les policiers que nous
côtoyons sur les manifestations
tout se passe bien sauf quand ya ce
dérapage avec des gendarmes qui nous
disent en off bas on avait ordre d'être
plus nombreux que vous à la fin de la
manifestation
donc effectivement allons plus loin est
ce qu'ils ont eu ordre également de nous
poursuivre par la suite moi je voudrais
juste relater ce qui s'est passé ce
week-end samedi sur la manifestation du
1er mai avec un tweet de commissaire de
police
sii cp qui nous ils n'ont plus peur de
rien en plein jour dans la manifestation
un policier violemment agressé par un
voyou sous l'oeil des caméras et des
témoins
seuls les policiers lui porteront
secours le spectacle visiblement doit
primer moi je m'inquiète je crois qu'on
arrive proche du jour où on va nous dire
mais messieurs dames les journalistes il
ya de la violence c'est parce qu'il ya
des caméras vous êtes là donc ça incite
les gens à dépasser la borne qui nous
disent ah là c'est un syndicat de
commissaires de police
est ce que réellement on essaye de nous
monter les uns contre les autres les
policiers les gendarmes contre les
journalistes
sous prétexte que ce serait nous qui
attise aurions les motifs de
manifestations et la violence dans les
manifestations
moi je m'inquiète vraiment de ça et je
suis ravi de pouvoir aller échanger
qu'alexandre l'emploi qui semble être un
policier sens et de terrain et qui a
constaté comme moi qu'on pouvait se
parler sur le terrain sur une
manifestation et chacun fait son travail
son problème de narnia un autre aspect
je voulais vous faire entendre celui
évoqué par le grand reporter fondateur
de la plateforme média et démocratie
olivier pineau et côté ski pouvoir ont
globalement saisi le prétexte de la
crise du coc vite 19 pour accentuer leur
volonté de maîtrise des médias
alors ça y va franco c'est un prétexte
cette crise sanitaire pour accentuer la
volonté de maîtrise des médias alexandre
langlois c'est un petit bout votre
sentiment également sur le terrain
évidemment ça va même dans le sens même
le secrétaire général de l'onu a fait un
rapport dans ce sens là donc on est
vraiment dans un contrôle des médias
même le journal anglais the economist
qui avait déclassé la france en
démocratie défaillante suite à sa
gestion de la crise qu vide donc il ya
vraiment un problème qui fait qu'on veut
cacher les choses on ne veut pas faire
les choses et on voit bien qu'on est
dans la communication qu'on est capable
par exemple de déployé des milliers de
policiers pour vérifier des attestations
et par contre pour lutter contre le
trafic de drogue on met un numéro vert
en place à tel point que même des gens
comme le préfet de police de marseille
qui depuis a été remercié pour ses bons
et loyaux services avait déclaré que
c'était un problème sur les attestations
et y avec les dealers qui les avait pas
alors que six aprem de santé publique
vente de la drogue est quand même un
petit peu plus grave qu'une attestation
donc à se contrôler cette mainmise on ne
veut pas que les choses sortent ce
contrôle devait effectivement de un
petit peu partout et georges bach
exemple qui était sorti le budget par
exemple de l'elysée pour contrôler sa
réputation sur les réseaux sociaux est
supérieur au budget
pour le forum de la laïcité présidée par
marlène schiappa donc on voit bien
l'ordre de priorité c'est qu'on est sur
une guerre de l'image une guerre de la
presse et on n'est plus du tout sur fond
de là on est sûr de la propagande
techniquement il y avait un autre
exemple qui avait été assez marquant
c'était la ferme et chez les éclairs on
a eu des images donc de violences
policières et du coup la réponse de
monsieur darmana a été quelques semaines
après deux films et un policier lors
d'une manifestation qui se fait défoncer
la mâchoire et on est quasiment
persuadés comme milité en main cas de
l'or ne peut agir que sur ans et que
soit ils ont été mal commandé ça c'est
un fait
mais ce qu'ils n'ont pas été mal
commandé exprès pour faire des images
donc on est sur une guerre image contre
image fait que nous conte fait que
youssoupha on est sur quelque chose de
complètement aberrant il serait temps de
remettre la vérité l'information et les
gens puissent se forger leur opinion que
le jour où il n'y a plus de place libre
les gens que ce pub se forger une
opinion et on peut les manipuler
alors on lisait un rapport un énième
peut-être un pour être taquin commandé
par le gouvernement en décembre dernier
a été remis hier au premier ministre
avec 32 composition regarder ce
communiqué de matignon
le rapport argumenté équilibrée permet
au gouvernement de travailler à établir
une relation plus sereine et un cadre de
dialogue renforcé entre la presse et les
forces de l'ordre
un comité de suivi sera installée à cet
effet dans les prochains jours il sera
décliné au plan local par des instances
de dialogue permettant de partager les
contraintes propres à chaque métier
alors c'est vrai mais dessus et on est
spécialiste des rapports avant dans ce
pays on est content plus alors par
exemple celui ci propose parmi les 32
propositions donc de permettre aux
journalistes de se placer derrière les
cordons des forces de l'ordre pour
garantir leur sécurité physique
c'est ce genre de mesure vers lesquels
il faut aller non je crois pas pas du
tout effectivement les forces de l'ordre
doivent assurer la sécurité des
journalistes présents sur une
manifestation
mais la couverture d'une manifestation
elle est totale ou alors elle ne l'est
pas ça veut quand même dire une chose ça
veut dire qu'en fait on aura le droit de
filmer de faire notre travail à un
certain endroit de la manifestation moi
je crois pas que
aujourd'hui quand on va courir une
manifestation on doit nous restreindre
hall le
lieu où on doit filmer ou rapporter ce
qui s'est passé à un endroit de la
manifestation quand les cortèges
sentiment s'il peut se passer énormément
de choses dans dans les cortèges
non non moi je je je pense que c'est une
dérive
le rapport recommande également je cite
clairement aux forces de l'ordre
de quelles peuvent en principe s'opposer
à la captation d'image ou de sons des
opérations menées dans des lieux publics
alexandre l'angoissent ça vous inspire
quoi toutes ces propositions que c'est
comme depuis que les manceaux qu'on veut
pas régler un problème on réunit deux
commissions on demande de réunir ces
propositions des recommandations qui ne
seront pas appliquées on a pu voir ce
qui s'est passé sur la convention sur le
climat toujours des résultats
par contre qu'est ce que ça inspire
s'inscrit aucun amalgame un mélange des
genres
non parce qu'effectivement il ya
certaines opérations de police disent
ici que la discrétion ces démissions
secret défense des jets et 6 contre
terrorisme police judiciaire sur
certaines interpellations et en fait ce
gouvernement a l'art de tout mélanger et
ça effectivement il ya des missions qui
peuvent être protégées
mais le maintien de l'ordre l'émission
quotidienne sur le terrain les
conditions de la police oui je veux dire
quotidienne n'y a pas de raison de
paniquer en train de mettre des
situations compliquées au nom de
l'audition des policiers ce qui n'est
pas vrai elle est déjà protégée textes
existants encore faudrait-il qu'ils
soient appliquées hélas une fois
celui-ci a pas de volonté du
gouvernement les applique
et on est vraiment sûr de la propagande
de la chemise m'ont fait discuter des
gens on oppose les personnes et pendant
qu'on discute de tous ces sujets là pas
par exemple ne fait pas son travail sur
deux sujets à couvrir une en train de se
battre pour justement la presse m le mot
de la fin pour vous si vous deviez
justement vous si vous êtes des dieux
participé à ce rapport qu'auriez vous
proposer qu'est ce qui manque
aujourd'hui clairement pardon je vais
répondre à côté stéphanie de mu rue mais
je crois que j'ai pas lu le même rapport
recommandation numéro trois a rappelé
clairement aux forces de l'ordre
qu'elles ne peuvent en principe
s'opposer à la captation d'image ou de
sons des opérations qu'il mène dans les
lieux publics que celle ci soit le fait
de journalistes ou de toute autre
personne
je crois qu'il ya quand même des bonnes
choses dans ce rapport je ne veux pas
voir tout blanc ou tout noir
il faut continuer de défendre cette
liberté de la presse veiller au grain et
il faudra toujours le faire mais je
crois qu'on s'est mal compris sur cette
recommandation numéro 3
un mot peut-être alexandre langlois une
réponse c'est à dire que cette
recommandation en fête existe déjà dans
la loi donc en fait on est en train
d'enfoncer des portes s'ouvrirent donc
une fois de plus eu appliquons la loi ce
qui ne fait pas ce gouvernement ce qui
est assez dramatique et je repenserai
toujours à un sondage qui avait été fait
près de dix mille policiers qu'est ce
que vous demanderiez en premier au mini
stade lat or si vous pouviez changer
qu'une chose la réponse a été à 70% que
le ministère de l'intérieur respecte la
loi
donc voilà on en est là on est en train
de faire des recommandations tout ça
mais appliquant ce qui existe on aura
déjà réglé beaucoup de choses merci en
tout cas tous les deux mètres du but un
rédacteur en chef
h 2 o 1 radio et non pas lâchement radio
merci à vous langlois d'avoir été avec
nous pour ce face à face